[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينحدر القارئ ابراهيم ايت احمد من منطقه
زاكوره جنوبيه المغرب نشا في مدينه الدار
البيضاء وفيها حفظ القران الكريم على يد
عدد من كبار شيوخ الاقراء المغاربه
بالطريقه العتيقه
ولتحفيزه على الحفظ والتعمق في دراسه
القران الكريم واحكامه ارسلته العائله الى
مدينه طنجه التي تردد على عدد من مدارسها
التقليديه متما حفظ القران الكريم كاملا
ليعود الى الدار البيضاء اماما وقارئا في
مساجدها
في بدايه الامر هو الحمد لله امنا الله
عليه يعني بعائله محافظه نشات بها في
مدينه الدار البيضاء
يعني كنا في سن يعني الخامسه او السادسه
كنا نتعلم مع الوالد حفظه الله في البيت
يعني لما كنت اتابع دراستي يعني في
الابتدائي في كلمه كان معي يعني هناك بعض
الاطفال يعني يشتغلون بحفظ القران وكذا
ومن هنا كانت البدايه يعني كنت يعني اقول
للوالد اريد ان اهاجر
فكانت تراودني هذه الفكره وكان يعني بعض
الاخوه كانوا ياتون من طنجه يعني ياتون من
طنجه يعني الاجتياز مباراه التجويد في
حينا انذاك حي الفرح
فسبحان الله كنت يعني مشتاق لاتمامي حفظ
القران
ومغادره مدينه التي كنت اخطن بها انذاك
وهي مدينه الدار البيضاء
فصراحه
بعدما خلصت المستوى الخامس ابتدائي
وكنت متفوقا يعني في الدراسه
فجئت ابكي الى البيت
ولست واتذكر تلك اللحظه فاخذت امي الهاتف
تبحث يعني عن مدارس عتيقه في مدينه طنجه
واتصلت يعني بالمجلس العلمي بالرباط ثم
يعني دلوها على احد المساجد وهو مسجد عمر
بن الخطاب
التابع لمسجد النور بحي مصدر خوش في طنجه
حفظت عشرين حزبا في الدار البيضاء على
الشيخ الحسين العفاسي حفظه الله بمسجد
العباسي في حينا هذا جمعيه حي الفرح
لتحفيظ القران الكريم ثم انطلقت مع الوالد
حفظه الله الى مدينه طنجه ولاول مره كنت
اترك عائلتي وكنت يعني اهاجر يعني لوحدي
وكنت في سنه كان عندي انذاك عشر سنوات
فرحب بي المدير اسال الله عز وجل ان
يشفيها وان يعافيها وهو علي تشيوا
في مدرسه عمر بن الخطاب
وكنت احفظ القران على الشيخ عبد العزيز
الجحيم رحمه الله توفي قبل ثلاث سنوات
فاتممت حفظ كتاب الله عز وجل
وشاركته في عده مسابقه التجويد انذاك
والحمد لله كنت من المتفوقين بفضل الله عز
وجل ثم بفضل الوالد والمجهودات التي يعني
كنا نقوم بها في تلك المؤسسه
بعدها يعني لما اتممت حفظ كتاب الله ويعني
احنا عندنا يعني في العاده ان الانسان
يحفظ القران يعني في المغرب يعني على
الاقل ثلاث سلكات يعني السلكه عندنا في
المغرب يصطلح عليه يعني لما تمر يعني مره
واحده يعني من اعوذ برب الناس الى سوره
البقره تسمى سلكه يعني دور يعني دوره
واحده فالحمد لله انا يعني كان لي حظ وافر
يعني في السلكه الاولى تقريبا اربعين حزب
حفيظ عن ظهر قلب لان الامام يعني كان يعني
يعاملني مثل يعني معامله الاب مع ابنه حيث
يعني لم يكن هناك
في طنجه وكنت يعني مغتربا فالحمد لله
يعني لا اذكر يعني خيره وفضله عليه
ومن ثم يعني لما اتممت دراستي هناك
درست بعض العلوم علوم الاله وكذا في في
مدرسه عمر بن الخطاب وبعدها انتقلت الى
مدينه الدار البيضاء رجعت اليها بعد ان
حصلت على شهاده
شهاده الاجازه في الدراسات الاسلاميه
تخصص يعني كان عندي تخصص
مقارنه الاديان يعني القراءه يعني بالنسبه
للتجويد يعني بدات اتعلم التجويد
وقواعد التجويد الى غير ذلك قبل ان احفظ
القران في مدينه الدار البيضاء كانت عندي
تسع سنوات وكنت ادرس في احد المساجد ويسمى
مسجد السلام عند الشيخ عبد العاطي ومعروف
يعني كان كانت عنده يعني دورات يوم الخميس
والجمعه والسبت والاحد وكنت لازلت صبيا
كنت اصغر واحد يعني في المجموعه فالحمد
لله يعني
انتفعت منه كثيرا واخذت منه الخير الوفير
بفضل الله عز وجل ثم بعدها انتقلت الى
طنجه يعني حفت القران هناك
وصراحه يعني فكره الامامه لم تكن يعني
تراوضني يعني كنت احفظ القران لحفظ القران
ليس لازاول مهمه الامامه او غير ذلك
فكنت اشتغل بالتجاره مع الوالد في الدار
البيضاء
وشاءت قدره الله عز وجل يوما
افتتحت احد المساجد يعني في حينا فطلب مني
احد الاخوه يعني ان
الناس هناك فكنت اماما يعني متطوحا
يعني كنت اصلي بهم فقط الصلاه الجهريه مثل
صلاه المغرب والعشاء وصلاه الصبح فقط اما
بالصباح كنت اشتغل مع الوالد في التجاره
الحمد لله مدينه الدار البيضاء معروفه
بالمقرئين معروفه يعني بالقراء مدينه
الدار البيضاء
وكان هناك تنافس كثير يعني يعني اذكر يعني
عندما كنت صغيرا حتى في حينا ولله الحمد
يعني يعني كانت مجموعه مجموعه من ابناء
حيينا الحمد لله كانوا كلهم يعني يمارسون
التجويد والمقامات وكنا يعني نتنافس فيما
بعد فيما بيننا يعني حتى كنا يعني نشارك
في مسابقات كثيره ابناء حي الفرح اذكروا
منهم صديقي معاذ رمران يعني هادو كلهم
مقرئين وعاد رمرام عبد الصمد رمرام مصطفى
ايد بوعلي يعني كانوا مقرئين كثر ولله
الحمد
يعني المقرئ الذي كنت يعني يعني بدات يعني
في بدايه صوري وهو الشيخ الحذيفي حفظه
الله كنت متاثرا به في صغارنا
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
تبارك الذي جعل في الس
ماء بروجا
وجعل فيها سراجا وقمرا منيرا
وهو الذي جعل الليل
والنهار خلفه لمن
اراد
لمن اراد ان يذكر اوراد شكورا
وعباد الرحمن الذين يمشون على الارض لولا
واذا
خاطبهم الجاهلون قالوا سلاما
والذين يبيتون لربهم سجدا وقياما
والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف
عنا عذاب ج
هن
ان عذابا كان غراما
انها
ساءت مستقرا ومقاما
والذين
اذا قولوا لم يسرفوا ولم يقتروا وكان بين
ذلك قواما
[موسيقى]
والذين لا يدعون
معه الهنا
ولا يقتلون
النفس التي حرم الله الا بالحق ولا يزن
ون
ومن يفعل ذلك يلقى اثامى
[موسيقى]
يضاعف له العذاب يوم القيامه ويخلد فيهم
هانا
الا من تاب
وامن وعمل عملا صالحا
فا
ولئك يبدلون الله
سيئاتهم حسنات
وكان الله
غفورا رحيما
ومن تاب وعمل صالح
ا فانه
يتوب
فانه يتوب الى الله متابا
[موسيقى]
والذين لا يشهدون
واذا مروا باللغو مروا كراما
والذين اذا ذكروا
بايات ربهم لم يخروا عليها
صما وعميانا
[موسيقى]
والذين يقولون ربنا هب لنا من ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين
وجعلنا للمتقين امام
[موسيقى]
ا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد تجربه الناجحه مع الامامه والخطابه في
مدينه الدار البيضاء المغربيه التحق
القارئ ابراهيم ايه الحسن الى بلجيكا
مستقرا بها وليتولى ايضا الامامه في منطقه
مولمبيك وهي احدى اكبر الاحياء البلجيكيه
اكتظاظا بالجليات المسلمه يتولى تدريس
القران الكريم للناشئه من ابناء الجاليه
المغربيه كما يتولى حاليا الامامه في مسجد
الامل بمنطقه اندرلخت وهي من اكبر تجمعات
المغاربه في بروكسل تجد ان الامام يعني
هنا يعني انطلاقا من يعني وظيفته الامامه
يعني يمارس عده ادوار
مثلا الدور الديني الذي هو يعني دور
الديني الصرف مثل الامامه والخطابه يعني
ارشاد واجوبه يعني الناس على اسئلتهم من
غير ذلك وتجد كذلك يعني من بين الادوار
الدور الثقافي ان الامام هو يعني ذاك
الرجل يعني الحارس الامين للهويه للثقافه
يعني
للجماعه يعني في هذا البلد ثم كذلك يعني
من بين الادوار
الدور يعني
تقول يعني ممكن ان يطلق عليه الدور يعني
فتجد الامام هو ذلك الشخص الذي يحل يعني
النزاعات والخلافات يعني بين الافراد
والاسر فكثيرا لتجدون كثيرا من العائلات
قبل ان يلجاوا يعني الى السلطات وكذا
يلجاون الى الامام لحل نزاعاتهم يعني
بالتي هي احسن
يعني الاستماع الازواج احيانا قبل يعني ان
يتم الطلاق ياتون الى الامام وبفضل الله
يعني يعني تجد الامام يعني لابد ان يكون
صلبا فالحمد لله انا صراحه يعني بعدما
اتيت الى هذه البلاد استفدت كثيرا يعني
هناك رابطه الائمه يعني يعني تعقيد الكثير
يعني من الندوات يعني في تكوين الائمه
وكذلك المجلس العلمي كنت حضرت السنه
الماضيه يعني كانت هناك يعني ندوه يعني
تحت الامامه في اوروبا والحمد لله استفدنا
منها كثيرا يعني حضرها تقريبا ازيد من 300
امام في اوروبا يعني اتوا من ايطاليا من
اسبانيا من المانيا فكما قلت لك الامام
يحتاج الى ان يكون يعني ذا خبله يعني
كثيره هو الانشطه يعني في اوروبا يعني
تختلف من مسجد الى اخر على حسب يعني على
حسب يعني المسؤولين وهكذا يعني على سبيل
المثال في مسجدنا هذا ولله الحمد يعني تجد
ان المسجد يعني نشيط جدا
هناك يعني قسم للشباب
ويعني كذلك يعني قسم يعني للنساء اللي
عندهم دروس يعني في الاسبوعيه باللغه
العربيه وبالفرنسيه وكذلك هناك دروس المحو
الاميه للناس الكبار في السن الذين يعني
يريدون ان يتعلموا اللغه العربيه وحفظ
القران الى غير ذلك
وكذلك يعني نحن نشتغل كذلك بتحفيظ كتاب
الله عز وجل يوم السبت والاحد وممكن نقول
يعني في العطل العطل الرسميه للاطفال
فالحمد لله يعني في مؤسستنا هذه عندنا
تقريبا
مئه طفل يحفظون كتاب الله عز وجل
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان الرجيم
[موسيقى]
الاخ
لاص يومئذ بعضهم لبعض
[موسيقى]
عن الا المتقين
يا عبادي لا خوف عليكم اليوم
ولا انتم تحزنون
[موسيقى]
الذين
امنوا
باياتنا
وكانوا مسلمين
[موسيقى]
ادخلوا الجنه
انتم
وازواجكم تحض
[موسيقى]
رون يطاف عليهم
بصحاف
من ذهب وا
[موسيقى]
وفيها ما تشتهيه الى انفس وتلذذ لا
وانتم فيها خالد
[موسيقى]
ون وتلك الجنه
التي
اورثتموها بما كنتم تعملون
لكم فيها فاكهه
لكم فيها
فاكهه
كثيره منها
[موسيقى]
تزخر بكثير من الائمه ما شاء الله اما
يعني لدينا يعني يشهد لهم يعني
بالاتقان وبالقواعد لا غير ذلك مثل الشيخ
حمدان طيب حمدان مثل الشيخ معروف كذلك
ويعني
دائما على على طيله سنه هناك يعني يتم
يعني استدعاء ائمه يعني مثل الشيخ الكوشي
عيون الكوشي مثل الشيخ قيراوي اي من
المغرب ياتون يعني طيله سنه انظم يعني
ننظم امسيات قرانيه وتكون هناك كذلك يعني
مسابقات لتجويد للاطفال تحفيزيه كذلك له
طعم خاص رمضان صراحه يعني يختلف عن المغرب
هذا الذي يعني انا زاولت يعني امام في
المغرب عن صلاه التراويح في المغرب يعني
كذلك يعني نصلي بالناس هنا لعده سنين هناك
فرقتين
ما شاء الله يعني
تجد ان الانسان يعني يعني
متعطش لسماع كتاب الله عز وجل وحتى يعني
يعني المسجد يكون ممتلئ عن اخره
يعني عندنا كما رايتم يعني عندنا يعني
طابق الاول والثاني والثالث وكذلك يعني في
الاسفل يعني يمتلئ عن اخره وكذلك يعني في
صلاه التراويح بعد العشاء وكذلك في صلاه
يعني التهجد فالحمد لله يكون هناك اقبال
يعني كثير على على صلاه التراويح حوالي
الله الحمد
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم ملك
يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
الين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات